[Music]  today is a sad day for europe  our union loses a passionate european  a sincere democrat  and a good man  david sasoli  was a man of deep faith and strong  convictions  everyone loved his smile and his  kindness  yet he knew how to fight for what he  believed in  in 1989 he was in berlin  among the young europeans when the wall  came down  and ever since  he has stood on the side of democracy  and of a united europe  and over a decade of service in the  european parliament  he constantly defended our union and its  values  but he also believed that europe had to  strive for more  he wanted europe to be more united  closer to its people  more faithful to our values  that's his legacy  and that's how i will remember him  as a champion of justice and solidarity  and a dear friend  my thoughts are with his wife alessandra  and his children giulio and livia  and all his friends  amico  amici